[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
SVD and now we're getting into some of
the key details that you have to keep in
mind when you're actually using the SVD
for data processing and especially for
scientific computing and so one of the
really really important things I want to
bring up is the importance when you're
doing the SVD of data alignment so
alignment and invariance and I'll tell
you what this means in a minute I mean
translational and rotational and
variances of your data okay so when you
build your data matrix X X again let's
say that this is the human faces example
X 1 X 2 dot X M there is an implicit
assumption because this is based on that
correlation matrix of X transpose times
X or X times X transpose where are you
taking inner products of all of these
columns of X with each other there's
this fundamental assumption that every
row of X means the same thing from
person to person okay so when I take
person 1 and I take person 2 let's say
this is you know X 1 and X 2 and I take
their dot product there is an assumption
that when I dot product the pixel
corresponding to the eyes that it's this
it's it means an eye in both images that
that pixel is at the location of the eye
in both images and the mouse is at the
same location in both images okay if I
have an example where my data is not
kind of aligned so I have you know a
person over here and a person over here
so that they're kind of translated I'm
going to get a terrible singular value
decomposition because now I'm not
comparing eyes with eyes and noses with
noses and mouths with mouths I'm
comparing eyes with space okay and cheek
with eye and things like that so it
doesn't make any sense if the data is
not aligned so we assume that our data
is aligned and cropped so that Apple
it's
an apples-to-apples comparison whereas
if you have this kind of translation of
the thing you care about in your image
the SVG is going to be a really poor
method for pulling out features because
it's just not gonna work okay and that's
actually one of the reasons that in the
early Facebook face recognition
algorithms what they would do is they
would actually the first thing they
would do is they would pick out the
corners of the eyes the corners of the
nose and the corners of the mouth and
they would map it onto a standard
stencil so that everyone's eyes nose and
mouth were at the same kind of geometry
so even if even if one person had maybe
wider eyes and a taller face or narrow
our eyes and a shorter face they would
get mapped on to this standard template
so that the pixels in the mouth region
the nose region and the eye region could
be compared apples to apples from image
to image and that gives you a much much
better classification performance and
dimensionality reduction feature
extraction just by cropping and aligning
your data okay so we as humans have this
innate ability to recognize
translational invariance in images okay
so if I see an image of a truck
over here or a truck over here doesn't
make much of a difference to me it makes
a huge difference to the SVD and to
image classification so you have to
really crop and align based on the
object you're you're looking for okay
other examples of invariance is that the
SVD cannot handle very well that we can
handle our rotations so in fact humans
have a really good sense of what I'm
going to call camera symmetries so if
you look at an object from any different
perspective you can you know very easily
tell what that object is and classify it
regardless of translations rotations and
scale and variances again not so for the
singular value decomposition this is not
built to have those invariances of
translation rotation and scale modern
methods in optimization are starting to
get dimensionality reduction that has
and variances and in fact that's why
people like convolutional neural network
so much is because they capture this
translational invariance that is so easy
for us to handle an images so another
example I like to show and I'm gonna
code this up in MATLAB and Python is
this idea that if I have a data matrix X
that looks like this where I'm gonna
shade it in that means that the value is
1 and the clear region means that a
value is 0 so this is my data matrix X
this is a Rank 1 matrix there is one
object there's one linearly independent
row and column that describes this
entire data matrix ok maybe 3 - I think
it's yeah it's low rank a low rank data
matrix but if I start to rotate that
square then and compute the SVD my rank
is going to increase and increase and
increase and increase until when I have
a diamond like this again it's the same
object to us humans we recognize that
this is the same low rank object that
this is except now when I compute the
SVD because it's doing row wise and
column wise correlations this has very
high rank maybe you know in the hundreds
depending on the resolution of the image
just might have a rank of a hundred even
though we recognize that it's still kind
of a 1 Rank 1 object it's like one
coherent square we just rotated it so
that's a cautionary tale that you have
to be very careful when you're using the
SVD for systems with translations
rotations scale invariance especially if
you're using this to build dynamical
systems models like gelec and projection
models if this is a physical system
evolving in time if you take the SVD of
a travelling wave as it goes from left
to right you're not going to get one
coherent wave with a wave speed you're
gonna get some weird linear combination
of this wave at lots and lots of
positions along its track and it's not
going to make physical sense so I want
to point this out you know if this
matrix X has the meaning
X has spacial so let's call this space
and time dimensions so it's some spatial
measurement evolving in time then the
SVD is essentially going to give you a
space time separation of variables just
like what we do in solving partial
differential equations just like what we
do with the Fourier transform and so if
you have a system that has traveling
waves or rotations or scale in variances
this isn't going to work very well okay
big caution big caveat and it's actually
a pretty exciting area of ongoing
research is how to take these these very
simple linear algebra techniques and
adapt them so that they can handle
rotations and translations and things
like that
okay so we'll code this up and see how
it works and kind of see these pitfalls
in code next thank you